yeah welcome to yet another five-minute
blitz game and I'm playing the French
two hands classical variation and
probably would get unknown fr would be
the the starlet's line okay neither
three is the possibility exam the peace
play variation where white um doesn't
play with that form yeah black can play
Bishop them c5 and also night c5 it's
also not not bad done I'm not sure is it
f6 here like place a quick f6 and this
position and I forgot I forgot the line
let's just them play some normal-looking
a developing moves is it f six not sure
yeah he goes for long castles but I
haven't canceled yet so maybe I'm maybe
i can even contemplate 22 castle long on
or maybe do i need to castle actually
it's not
it's not clear to me if I if I need to
really can play let's say rook c8 and I
know a 6b five and so on the only piece
that's not playing is the look on age 8
and I see this way he wants to wants to
tech the g7 corn and maybe also use some
the rook on the third-ranked for
defensive purposes okay rook g3 I could
maybe answer with Bishop f8 or King
evade king of AIDS I don't know but it's
not clear how wide would actually am
improve further okay I try to prepare be
five yeah I cannot go up g8 Bishop fa to
some it's really slow and king of eight
yeah but what does this big idea after
king of eight come on let's let's do
that I don't start out see yet how white
improves and I mean I'm going for be
five before let's hope but it isn't so
bad one thing about not playing with f4
here as he decided on move five is that
you don't have any pawn breaks I mean
you don't have f4 f5 g4 g5g 45 after
Luke g3 ism is difficult and you cannot
use the f porn so how how is white going
to yes something like that I thought
about that you need to move for move
pieces all right so be five or takes and
b5 maybe takes mp5
I can also go nite a 4 here night a form
he takes Queen tags threatening them on
c2 and it's so bad the same perform
mostly rotated me a bit if he takes I
could also just take with the bishop I
don't need to eat change with the Queen
a form it shouldn't be bad down Queen fo
I don't really think after Queens I
exchange them that I am should have any
any problems Bishop Bishop retreat
interesting so what about Queen to see 5
go into c-5m maybe you go Quincy form
not sure that I want that okay come on
let's just take this and play Queen a
form after this you need to move the
Queen and you cannot go to G form
he basically needs to retreat now one
idea is Bishop b5 getting rid of this
I'm slightly worse bishop he also must
be cautious about the sea to bond so
let's say queen III I could I Bishop
before it's not great llame can take
with the check so see to us not really
am not really hanging okay I want to get
rid of the bishop Oh Brooke deform rocky
form could be a embarrassing immediately
spotted this after after I played the
move and where do I go I can take d4 and
take everyone but this is certainly not
enough how about a shame property form
ooh Bishop c4 yeah he's got be three
look you for don't really have a move
probably need to sack the Queen yeah
took him a while but it is good Bishop
c5 this is possible rook a4 Wow rookie
for Bishop e3 maybe everything else
seems to seems to lose anyway okay so
but now i can i can take everywhere
right i can take f2f1 it's a take wait
wait we'll wait the heck just just just
for a second what is going on I can take
f1 and then you would take III yo Justin
the [ __ ] in the problem ok I see that
I can also take f2 yeah come on take F
to this is this is easier now maybe the
shop push it back here again probably I
shouldn't have spent so much time
probably I wasn't worth it
I'm fine here but okay he's not
particularly quick also rooks III I
expected rooks III and when something
landed on her on c3 I was just moving
takes with the pawn a playbook c4 I am
getting rid of one look and then I can
actually move move here yeah this is now
now winning for her black tea for
threatened now the heck mouth slip I
wanted to take on c3 and get to the king
and porn endgame yeah I wasn't too too
quick but he was slower even I need to
adjust to new mouse I just thought
bought a new mouse yesterday and it it's
a great great this thing is working
great but I need to adjust to it anyway
yeah I somehow wriggled out of out of
this I did it looked a bit a bit bit
strange I really overlooked Luke t4 and
it took took me awhile to see Bishop c5
even and the computers as usual wow this
is a queer apply the computer just wants
to go Queen to d2 here let's let's let's
look at this briefly I
oops this was too much I'm curious yeah
here I need to place a mother move
rookie phone Bishop c5 and now instead
of this it wants to go here Bishop d4
and then be three this is really cool
what what does black supposed to do now
if I take on c3 here he just recaptures
the queen is still attacked so what move
now I don't ever move CA designing if i
take here he gets the Queen and I'm I'm
also completely am yeah there's no
coordination in this position otherwise
maybe it is something but I lose I lose
material instantly because I'm not
coordinated at all and well after he
missed his chance of thinking it was
probably a probably not so bad this is
getting too starting to get good good
for black yeah thanks for watching